ach das holz her stimmt das volk dreht
sich jetzt stimmt und das ist ja ne ich
raffe da ist gar nicht so viel
fast gar nichts ist da immer die items
die da sind
das wollte ich aber nicht du hört man
einfach nur deine schönen items okay das
war wahrscheinlich gerade einfach nur
diese fette flutwelle oder so ich hab
mich schon gewundert ob das die ganze
zeit so übels viele monster sind und
jetzt wirklich sagen begeben wir uns in
die bauphase des tempels aber erstmal
essen wir etwas was habe ich denn so
dadurch was also wollen wir denn hin
da wäre ein bisschen platz ich bin ja
eigentlich auch für da weil da haben wir
noch gar nicht stehen so wirklich die
haben wir ja schon alles voll gebaut
das heißt ich baue da einfach mal so ein
bisschen was ab hier oben die fläche
also wie gesagt erwartet jetzt nichts
großes ich kann selber gar nicht bauen
als ich bin total schlecht im baum und
er wird wahrscheinlich auch total kaka
aussehen der tempel aber einfach nur
damit wir noch so ein bisschen was bauen
weil so 10 11 12 folgen für so ein
projekt hier das ist ein bisschen wenig
aber naja die aufgaben waren ja relativ
schnell und einfach zu bewältigen muss
ich sagen und bei trauminsel damals
vielleicht kennt ihr es vielleicht kennt
ihr noch nicht habe ich dann mit skate
gemacht da war das nämlich damals auch
so dass wir das relativ schnell fertig
hatten wir haben einfach gesagt ja wir
brauchen wir wollen noch einen kuchen
den wir dann anbieten können und so
weiter also alle die das gesehen und
wissen jetzt was meine das hatten wir
endlich auch relativ schnell fertig und
deswegen haben wir uns da so eine
arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme zu herzen
genommen als einfach etwas anderes vorne
mit zelt
insgesamt ein bisschen witzige ein
bisschen schöner und allgemein bisschen
länger dauert
er wollte ja nicht projekt zum beispiel
wenn ich etwas mache wo man zum beispiel
oder so weit muss man ja sein wenn man
zwei drei aufgaben hat die man innerhalb
von ein paar tagen erledigen kann also
innerhalb von drei vier folgen dann ist
das ja nicht ganz so gut der sinn der
sache sein
übrigens wird es bald auf wie das länder
geben beziehungsweise wurde schon hoch
gelernt ich weiß es noch gar nicht weil
ich gerade relativ weit im voraus
aufnehmen weil ja auch wieder
klausurphase ist wenn ihr gerade das
video seht und da habe ich nicht so viel
zeit zum aufnehmen und weiter ihr wisst
was ich meine ja also bald kam dann auch
wieder ausländer oder kommt es schon all
kommt kommt genau konnte es kommt zu
schonen es kam schon es ist schon
gekommen es sei gekommen es wird
gekommen werden sein tun machen handeln
was weiß ich deutschland sei also etwas
für die castings erzählt habe ich
brauche holzfäller auf 367 toni polster
toll toll toll starbulls so stix habe
ich auch noch eine menge
das habe ich so viele sticks mein gott
was habe ich schon wieder angestellt und
zwar brauche ich weiß noch nicht genau
wie viele
ja das müsste eigentlich reichen alter
22 spieler brauche ich noch nicht nach
eger gut
auch wer pumpkin fällt mir grad auf wir
brauchen gar keine oder regal haben wir
eigentlich ein ich weiß es auch nicht
jedenfalls habe ich noch keinen pumpkin
gefunden so also ich denke so wird
ungefähr die größe betragen
da ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich den
kompletten platz ausnutzen werde
ich wollte auf jeden fall so ein
bisschen abgerundet machen
das ist halt blöd dass sie nicht im
creative mit bin so dass hier kann
erstmals weg das ist enstone ich nehme
so die melone als grenze für seinen
stores and jetzt geklappt höher geister
geisterholz brot also meine damen und
herren so das ist so der die stufen zum
eingang sage ich mal
moment mal
ach das ist ein hund ich dachte schon er
irgendein verrückter doch gerade um also
höre ich von dem man auf einmal und
hergelaufen okay dachte ich muss wieder
eingreifen
so was ich nehm ich dachte ist dass wir
das so machen
das war falsch und ich habe natürlich
keine achsen mit super super super duper
ist erhält in der welt so
das war sand ach mist dann eine extra
schon sonne ordnen dann verpasse ich die
also karten krampf habe ich versucht das
einfach ein bisschen sicher zu übertönen
das war schon wieder zu lang
so können wir das eigentlich machen
nächste mal einfach mal direkt daraus
also komplett nicht direkt direkt und
komplett einen großen unterschied
obwohl ich kann er theoretisch hier auch
dingen zu nehmen einfach toll 1 das
bringt jetzt auch die teile gibbs so
sieht jetzt noch blöd aus wird auch
nachher blöd aussehen glaube ich
eigentlich schon versprechen dass das
nachher auch ich kann einfach nicht
bauen
23 machen dann bauen wir mal so viel
hinaus wird nacht cool so übrigens bitte
nicht um wein wenn das projekt ihnen wie
dann zu ende ist oder so ich meine es
werden neue projekte kommt es wird ein
projekt kommen was wahrscheinlich ganz
cool sein wird was sich schon länger
versprochen habe wahrscheinlich weiß
kann eh keiner worum es geht weil es
schon lange her ist aber es gab
eigentlich auch relativ egal egal egal
tolle stimme gerade aufgestanden ich hab
so gedacht komm trink cdt sagen ja mal
besser die stimme und so bringt ziemlich
wenig also es gibt einen youtuber der
heißt klaus klaus kauka ist glaub ich
einfach ein paar videos wie man seine
stimme trainieren kann muss ich mal
befolgen also ich denke ich ihn mir mal
so vor ja kommen bei der nächsten
aufnahme folgst du hast dann hast du
auch voll die geile stimme und so ängste
total scheiße also ich meine meine
normale stimme hallt hatte 12345 zack
zack
so unglaublich das passt so gar nicht
gar nicht gedacht voll überrascht so die
ganze zeit geplant das passt sogar was
das denn eigentlich von mir seine so
hier noch unklar
hey wie sambia hat keinen fall egal
das grundgerüst steht also ihr seht
schon swg nichts großes ich kann ich
eigentlich schon wieder weg machen will
das nährte passt überhaupt nicht da
brauche ich auch diese teile hier am
besten hin abbau nachbarn ab paderborn
ich habe ja nicht mal extra bei der
verwandtschaft das dem rüberspringen
egal
langeweile zählt ja apropos langeweile
der posten ja auch manchmal immer leute
als ich weiß nicht wie ich immer auf die
themen komme der posten der mauer leute
dann so bei facebook
langeweile fdp und dann schreiben sie
der enz und kann so von den ja von
langeweile like diesem beitrag und ich
schreibe euch einsatz auf die pinnwand
einfach so so verdammt noch mal artig
ich meine wenn sie langeweile haben dann
sollen sie die für irgendwas nutzen sei
immer zum beispiel keine ahnung zimmer
aufräumen putzen lernen irgendwann
youtube videos machen meine eigentlich
ich finde ich finds mittlerweile echt
schon erstaunlich wie es manche leute in
unserer heutigen zeit sage ich mal
schaffen überhaupt langeweile zu haben
auch das holz her stimmt das volk
sicherheits stimmt
und das ist ja ne ich raffe michael so
acht wenig bestimmt die obere seite
ich verstehe gar nichts mehr tut mir
leid jetzt aber das ist doch einfach nur
behindert naja das hat auch wieder so
verstehe nicht auch wenn ich die untere
seite treffe wird schräg bestimmt na ja
das kann sein
keine ahnung blödes drehen anstatt dass
man das mit irgend so eine taste wenn
wir die gedrückt hält ausmachen kann
oder an machen kann alleine schon dann
wärs ja noch ganz cool und das wasser
axt ist da was ich habe eine axt bis da
was ich hoffe dax könnten welche monster
panschen gehen aber da habe ich nicht so
bock drauf gerade aber wir brauchen zwei
mal wieder denn ich brauche sind damit
ich mir so eine coole eisenachs oder
seine eisernen spitze machen kann
aber das projekt sehr bald auch schon
vorbei ist will ich sein lohnt sich das
auch eigentlich gar nicht hier können
wir lieber noch mit ein bisschen romand
ihren ich habe nämlich gerade überlegt
dass ich ein paar den kompletten rand
bei dem gebäude da bei dem tempel sage
ich mal dass ich denke es wird
keinesfalls aus dem tempel
aber ich gebe es ich gebe ihnen mal den
namen tempel ihm also dem ding da dass
ich den rand oben aus holzbalken so
liegend mache mir aber nicht sicher ob
das alles so funktioniert wie ich mir
das denke genug holz haben wir dafür auf
jeden fall also genug sei genug holz
haben wir allgemein schon auf jeden fall
weil wir haben anfang wie ich das glück
haben dass ihm hatten das im ersten baum
sofort setzlinge drin waren usw
es meinte auch einer den kommentaren
dass aus jedem baum ein setzling raus
kam deswegen hat er überhaupt nicht
verstanden warum ich mich da so so angst
hatte also ich hab bei skype blog auch
mal angst es da keinen sitzigen
rauskommt weil er ich weiß von von paul
plotek oder so keine ahnung
der hatte das damals so dass erst
gespielt hat hat beim baum gewartet und
da kam wirklich kleinen setzlingen raus
er wusste nicht ob das ein fehler war
oder einfach nur total blind waren
irgendwie fallen lassen hatte da so aber
es kann wirklich nichts raus obwohl das
ja eigentlich nicht möglich ist also
verstehen nicht naja ein fall für
galileo mystery was immer reicht das
jetzt überhaupt
ich werde jetzt alle bäume ab gefällt
aber ich habe irgendwie das gefühl das
reicht man nicht so ganz an bäumen an
holz so ich hatte erst mal die um andere
um andere um am boom boom die umwandlung
zu ende machen kann zweck verdammt ich
bin so ein talent ist er hier so
jetzt reicht es reicht es reich und
keine sorge kein panik auf der titanic
oh verdammt
moment ich mache das jetzt einfach so
passt schon
hauptsache es steht ich wollte schon
sagen hauptsache es sieht gut aus aber
das kannst du bei mir eigentlich gar
nicht sagen so eine kappe wieder
aktiviert ich sehe schon wieder tausend
sachen die nicht irgendwie symmetrisch
und passen will
du kannst einfach nicht bei und luca von
crafter lämmer zu bauen
die awo dvd view usw
kohl habe ich einen stick einstecken
steak soll ein steak na egal
reicht das noch um hier die decke
irgendwie fertig zu kriegen
jetzt freue ich mich gerade nein also
ich denke schon dass es reicht aber
verbaut so blöd so also dingens ist
fertig hier oben hätte ich endlich auch
am rande nacht kommen in der nähe ist
nicht egal das machen wir jetzt passt
schon
das ist dann so ungefähr der eingang
dann packen wir da noch eine tür rein
kann man da reingehen hallo guten tag
können wir einfach mal war blöd ich
trenne dass man hier so ein bisschen ab
so möchtegern wende fast alltag ist
wichtig hier schwer da wollte eigentlich
anders herum bauen moment ich zeige euch
wie so so so so so dann haben wir hier
in eingang haye ist passt cool ich nicht
gedacht so dann machen wir in der mitte
noch ein ach dadurch schon so dann haben
wir hier eingänge zu den jeweiligen
räumen die abgetrennt sind mit am
liebsten will ich jetzt mal hinsetzen
aber die gibt's da noch nicht dabei ist
ich mache das tier machen sich das aus
mit ja hat kann man lassen